حرب مصغره او السبقيه شنها له ماسك مالك
تويتر الجديد على شركه التكنولوجيا
العملاقه ابل ليفجر مفاجاه من العيار
الثقيل باعلانه ان الاخير قد توقف قد توقف
التطبيق من متجر ابل ستور فهل تستطيع ابل
القيام بذلك امر سهل للغايه وماسك نفسه
يعرف ذلك وهذا ما دفعه للتهديد بتصنيع
هاتف جديد ينافس ابل وجوجل اذا ما قاموا
بحذف تويتر من متاجر التطبيقات ابل فعلتها
سابقا فقط في يناير عام 2021 تطبيق الذي
كان يعتبر موطنا للمحافظين من الحزب
الجمهوري وماذا لانصار الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب وبرلت قرارها هذا
الذي جاء ذلك قبل ايام من اقتحام انصار
ترامب مبنى الكابتل الشهير في واشنطن بان
التطبيق انتهك قواعد بل وروش للعنف
والكراهيه هذا يعني انا ابل لديها الحق او
يمكنها على الاقل حضرت وتر لكن المساله
ليست بهذه البساطه مع تطبيق قوي وفعال مثل
تويتر لان حضره قد يفتح جدلا ونقاشا
قانونيا واسعا ومحتدما في الولايات
المتحده وغيرها طبعا من البلدان وقتي يدفع
حتى الى الكونجرس للتدخل